[AUDIO LOGO]
Welcome to the
Data Science Hangout.
I hope everybody is
having a great week
and are enjoying the
Shiny Conference.
Thank you so much to the
Appsilon team for putting
on this amazing conference and
for asking for the Data Science
Hangout to be a part of that.
It's really cool to be
included in the conference.
If somebody is here
from the Hangout
and doesn't know what I'm
talking about with the Shiny
Conference, can we share
the link in the chat
so they know how to join in to?
But I know we have
quite a few people here
joining the Data Science
Hangout for the very first time.
So thank you all so
much for joining us.
I'm Rachael Dempsey and I lead
our Pro community at Posit.
So we host this Data Science
Hangout every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
So what is it?
What's going on here?
This is our open space to chat
about data science leadership,
questions you're
facing, getting to hear
about what's going on
in the world of data
across different industries.
And so every week, we feature
a different data science leader
as my co-host to help lead
our discussion and answer
questions from you all.
There's no
presentations or slides.
Just all conversation
with everybody.
We're all dedicated to making
this a welcoming environment
for everyone.
And so we always love
to hear from everybody
no matter your level of
experience or area of work.
This is a bit different
than the Hopin platform
that you were in for
the Shiny Conference.
So I just want to make
people aware of that
to be a bit careful
with unmuting
and those things
that come with Zoom.
We'll be watching
out for it too,
but just wanted to
make that clear.
It is totally OK to
just listen in here.
But there's also three
ways that you can jump in.
So you can ask questions or
provide your own perspective
on certain topics by raising
your hand here on Zoom.
If you're not familiar
with Zoom, it's in the bar
below where it says Reactions.
If you click on that,
you can raise your hand.
But you can also put
questions in the Zoom chat.
And if you want, just put
a little star next to it
if you don't want to jump
in and read it yourself.
I'll know that maybe you're
in a coffee shop or something
and you me to read it.
And then lastly, we also
have a Slido link where you
can ask questions anonymously.
And our team here at
Posit will share that
into the chat in just a second.
We'll keep posting it
in there so that people
can find it as well.
It's great to see all
the messages in the chat.
We do share the
recordings of each session
to the Posit YouTube and our
Data Science Hangout site
so you can always go back
and rewatch or share it
with a friend.
But with all of that, thank
you so much for joining.
It's so amazing to see this big
group that we have here today.
And thank you so much,
David, for joining us
as our featured leader.
David Granjon is a senior
full stack Shiny developer
at Novartis and the founder and
maintainer of the open source
RinteRface organization where
he develops Shiny extensions
like bs4Dash and shinyMobile.
We also have Bo Wang, senior
expert data science at Novartis
who's also joining us
in the audience today.
We'll be helping with
any questions that
come up on their data monitoring
committees at Novartis as well.
So let me bring you both here
to introduce yourselves as well.
David, I'd love to have you
introduce yourself and maybe
share a little bit about
your role and also something
you like to do outside of work.
Yeah, sure.
Hi, everyone.
Thanks for having me.
I'm David Granjon.
I was born in
France 32 years ago.
I'm married.
I have one wonderful
daughter, a wonderful wife.
I'm doing data science at
Novartis since four years.
My background is about
applied mathematics.
So I have quite a sort
of Swiss knife background
where I can do physics,
I can do mathematics,
chemistry, a lot of
different things,
and also background
in web development.
So when I learned
web development,
I learned HTML, CSS, PHP and
also databases on the side.
I'm super glad I
was able to attend
the keynote before from Colleen
because I like sport a lot
as well.
I hate running, but
I like cycling a lot.
And probably for the
same reasons as Colleen.
So, at some point,
no matter what sport
you are doing, if it's making
you better, fitting you better,
having new IDs, taking some
insight of what you are doing,
that's just what you have to do.
We did have a really
fun picture of David
with his goggles on getting
ready to go out for a bike ride
that we might have to go
up with the recording too.
Thank you again, David.
Bo, so nice to
have you here too.
It'd be great to have you
introduce yourself as well.
If you want to jump in.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
First of all, I love
running and I hate biking.
I didn't know that
about you, David,
that you didn't like running.
Maybe we can team up as a
relay team in the triathlon
or something.
I hated biking when I tried it.
Anyway, so my name is Bo.
I work on the same team
as David in Novartis.
We are data scientists
who built tools,
pipelines to support our
clinical statisticians
and other data
science functions.
My background is
in biostatistics.
But since I started working
in the pharma industry,
I've been working on more
on the tool development,
almost like software
development side,
than actual trial analysis.
Although, I have been working
on supporting data monitoring
committees as Rachael
mentioned before
and there seem to
be a bit of interest
on that topic in
previous meetings.
So that's why I'm here.
Outside of work, like
I said, I like running,
I like travelling.
I'm actually right now
in Memphis, Tennessee
even though I'm normally
based in Boston.
I do not have a
wife or a daughter.
I do have a dog who I
treat as my daughter.
She's at my foot, napping
and that's pretty much it.
Glad to be here.
Thank you.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
And just a quick reminder
to everybody, if you're not
talking, if you want to just--
if you want to
just mute yourself,
it'll be really helpful too.
OK, cool.
Thank you so much.
So I get the pleasure
of being able to ask
some of the first
questions as we
wait for questions to come in.
But if anybody did just
join us after the initial
introductions, I
wanted to let you
know that you can ask
questions a few different ways.
So you can put questions
in to the Zoom chat.
You can also raise your hand
on Zoom and I'll call you in.
And we also have
a Slido link which
we'll share again where you can
ask questions anonymously too.
But something I was really
excited to start off
with asking is, David, I know
you think a lot about building
great user interfaces
and I was curious to hear
tips you have for all of us on
communicating with the business
through data visualizations.
Yeah, sure.
So I think we started a
big project last year,
which is around
probability of success.
And then for this
project, we really
thought about another way to
start our senior projects,
especially from the user
interface perspective.
So I would say, when
I joined Novartis
at the beginning,
most of the time,
we were rushing into
code, we developed
the interface, the app.
And then we showed the
app to the end user
and then they are not
happy with the result.
We completely
changed the process.
And with this project, we
basically start with wireframe.
So we've met with the user.
We draw the user requirements.
We discussed together
for one week, two weeks.
And then we present some
mockups, some wireframing.
So you could basically
use a paper and a pen
or you can use more
sophisticated tools.
I would say it's
a bit of a pity,
but most of the good wireframing
tools you have to pay.
We are using
Balsamiq at Novartis.
You may use it, you may not.
It depends if you know.
And then based on
that, we spend around
I would say, one month before
we can come to an agreement.
And then we can start to code.
So we really developed the
application of the end user.
That's just from
our perspective.
So it really satisfies
what they want.
Awesome.
Thank you.
I'm starting to see a lot of the
questions coming in the chat.
And thanks so much to the
Posit team for helping me
organize these.
But Libby, I see you
asked a question.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah.
I was just wondering
if we could get
an overview of some
of the big projects
that you've been
working on at Novartis.
I know that Novartis
is a pharma company
and that it's really big.
But being a person outside
of the pharma universe,
I sometimes don't know what
you guys are working on.
You want to start on this one,
Bo, and then I will take next.
Sure.
So two of the bigger projects
I've been working on,
one I've been working on
for a couple of years.
Basically, when a clinical
trial is being conducted,
there are a lot of data
analysis on the patient data
that we collect
from the enrollees.
And for later stage--
there are like earlier phases
trials and a small amount
of patients with lower doses.
And then once the
safety established,
you move on to later phases
with larger number of patients
and higher doses for efficacy
analysis for example.
But efficient safety
is always monitored
through all the phases.
And for later stage studies,
the "sponsor"-- in pharma lingo,
the sponsor's the
pharmaceutical company that
pays for the clinical trial--
anyone inside the
sponsor company
are not supposed to know
the actual treatment
of the patients
given if the study is
a randomized controlled trial.
So we need to hire
external partners.
Excuse me.
Excuse.
Me
Bless you.
Thank you.
We as sponsors have to
hire external experts
to be unblinded to the
actual treatment code
and review safety
data to make sure
that all the patients in the
ongoing trial are still safe.
So one of the big
projects that I've
been working on in the
past couple of years
is writing and managing
an app, a Shiny app,
that has a JavaScript backend
to display some of the safety
datas in a more user-friendly
way than say, 200 pages of PDF.
Because the DMC members tend
to be very highly regarded.
They're expensive-- their
time is very expensive.
Experts in their field, so
they have very limited time
that they can give us
to review the data.
So having an app as
a supplementary tool
aids their review of the
data with the limited time
that they have.
Thank you.
BO WANG: David, to you.
Since I joined Novartis, I
have been very lucky regarding
all the projects I received.
Surprisingly, at the beginning
like during my first months,
I was given a project
not about clinical data,
but for human resources data.
Because you have to
imagine, Novartis it's
like 100,000 people working and
then you have many departments.
It's not only clinical, but it's
also sales, human resources,
and many other things.
Basically, we had
to develop a tool
to better manage the time
people spend on projects.
And this tool was
basically first developed
with Shiny with a lot
of databases around just
to [INAUDIBLE] the
data assistant.
And then later, the
tool was improved using
other technologies like React.
But in the end, it
shows how you can
integrate Shiny in
the whole ecosystem
and that was a great project.
Then I joined the Probability
of Success Initiative, which
was a really rewarding
project because we really
had a checklist
and try to respect
all possible best
practices which
was this checklist was
based from the mistake we
made on all the projects.
And then we started
with the wireframing,
then we had a
strong CI/CD setup.
So we are responsible of
the CI/CD setup of the team.
So making sure we have--
so we are using
GitHub, so we have
runners with proper
installations,
then dependencies, everything.
So if you want to do headless
testing for your Shiny apps,
but you make sure that
the proper installation.
So setting up with runners
on how to manage the release,
you know, the
prediction release.
So this afternoon
during the conference,
we had the production
release for POS, the 1.0.0,
the first one, which is
like one year of work.
So that's quite a
big achievement.
I've also been involved--
so POS is clinical data, right?
I didn't really
give the background,
but when you work in
pharma, pharma companies,
they invest billions
into making a treatment.
It's not just like 10,000,
it's really billions.
So we need to make sure
what you are going to do
is successful at some point.
So you need to analyze
the market on everything.
And this probability
of success tools
provide a data-driven
solution to have
an improved diagnosis for
your probability of success.
And finally, I've been
involved in migration.
So it's more like in the
server infrastructure.
So to migrate from Shiny
Server Pro to RStudio Connect.
So initially, we
had Shiny Server Pro
and now we have RStudio
Connect so I had
to supervise this migration.
So essentially talking
about certain applications
and make sure this
application work correctly,
allows RStudio Connect,
Posit Connect now.
So that was quite
challenging because all
apps we are not necessarily
following all the best
practices.
Essentially, around
package dependencies.
So sometimes you are not
able to find whether where
a package is coming from
and the application was
just not working anymore.
So we did a lot of
work around our end
to set up reproducible
environments on many projects
which has a learning curve.
But yeah, we are
making progress, right?
Great.
Yeah, we are also tracking
usage in RStudio Connect--
so using the API, getting
the data of the server
to see how people are
using the applications
and stuff like that.
So that's very, not only
people data, that's all data.
That's awesome.
Cool to hear you're
using that API, too,
to get those advanced
usage metrics.
I'm seeing a ton of
questions coming in here too
and I want to make sure get
to the ones from the chat too.
And so, Sep, I see you had asked
a question around validation.
Do you want to jump
in and ask that?
Sure.
Thanks guys for jumping in
and sharing your stories.
I know, Bo already
kind of answered it,
but a validation is
usually, especially
in regulated industries, is
an arduous task generally.
And so I was kind
of really interested
to see is that something
that you guys had
built that required
validation to be undertaken?
Sometimes people have
alternatives to that.
So if you could speak to that
I guess a little bit more,
Bo or David, that
would be great.
Yes.
I think arduous
is the right word
to describe the whole
process as I discovered
in the past couple of years.
From my previous experience
in my work throughout
in my graduate school
career, I had never
encountered the issue of having
to validate a piece of software
or a piece of application.
Not in the code review
and testing sense,
but in the process
documentation sense.
So it was definitely
a learning curve.
And we have had a few
iterations of processes that are
based on software validation.
When I say software, you can
think of RStudio, the Shiny
Server, or the rsconnect
as a piece of software
that we have existing, processes
authored by IT to support.
But apparently, those
processes are a little--
there's a little
too much overhead
for a Shiny application.
So, in the past, I would
say, year and a half,
two years we've been
working with our QA
colleagues, our IT
colleagues, and our colleague
who are managing our deployment
system or analytical system
to communicate both ways.
What does quality mean
for our QA colleagues?
What does quality mean for IT?
What does quality
mean for business?
And try to reach
an understanding
of how much testing, how
much documentation is needed.
It's still an ongoing process.
We've had a few pilot projects
deploying apps for use in DMC,
but there are exceptions
for certain studies
that does not apply
to other studies.
So the solution
for certain issues
don't really translate
to long term solutions
that you can write
in the process,
in a business process on how to
validate a Shiny application.
So that's the part
that we're still
trying to figure out
as we incorporate
more different types of
studies in the program.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Travis, I see you had
a question as well.
And I forgot to
say, I know there's
a lot of people who are
here for the first time
so when you jump in
and ask your question,
if you want to
introduce yourself,
that would be awesome too.
And I would love to know where
you are outside right now.
Yeah, it's still San Diego.
It's nice here.
I saw a few of
your here in SoCal.
I'm Travis Gerke and I'm
also in the pharma CRO space.
And I'm a regular jokester
here on the Hangout in the chat
usually.
This is awesome.
I did have a question.
We also moved away
from 800 page PDFs
to more HTML-based products.
And it's been a game changer for
our safety monitoring boards.
They really like it.
But we're not as fancy as you.
What we're doing more reactable,
kind of static HTML documents
partly because of the
challenge which you
just discussed around
validation of Shiny Servers.
So I'm glad Sep
asked that question.
But one thing that's a
gap for us on the feedback
that we get from the monitors
is still this kind of clunky,
maybe they'll
write a long email,
or give us Excel sheets,
or other things back.
Are you thinking about or
have you gotten any feedback
from users writing
your app, which
seems a good opportunity
in the Shiny environment?
I'm trying to
understand your question.
Are you asking if we have
got positive feedback
on the format of the Shiny
application from the monitors?
No, actually on the
data points themselves.
So a lot of times, they'll
look at a patient profile
and, oh, this lab value,
are you sure this is right?
Or just the usual kinds of--
sometimes it's even data
quality questions which are
valid because the monitors are
often content matter experts,
medical experts and they see
things that we, as
data scientists, don't.
Yeah.
It would be very
convenient if while they're
looking at your app going
through what was previously
900 pages of PDFs, if they
could say, oh, like highlight
this and submit
right through the app
and you could get feedback in
that format rather than more--
Oh, I see.
--traditional methods.
No, we haven't incorporated
that in our app
to accept feedback directly in
the app from the DMC members.
In fact, the feedback
we've received
are mostly not directly
from DMC members,
even in the email chain,
because for pivotal studies,
for later phase studies,
we hire an external CRO
to interact with the
DMC members directly.
And we normally just
get feedback from them
because we're not
invited to the meetings
because we can't
risk unblinding.
Even though the developers
are not technically
part of the trial
team, but we are still
part of Novartis business.
That's one of the things that's
been part of my learning curve
also, how many
silos are intended
in the process of
clinical data review
just to make sure
data is secure.
But I'm sure David
might have something
to say about building
the function of feedback
into the app interface to
make it more user-friendly.
Yeah, that's a great
[INAUDIBLE] here from David,
yeah, because I guess I
asked my question from--
I'm in the CRO side
so that feedback loop
is something we're in and
you're on the sponsor side,
so you're right,
interesting silo
that we must adhere
to I suppose.
Any other thoughts, David?
Sorry.
I probably missed the last
part of Travis' question
about the user feedback, right?
Not sure I followed correctly,
Let me jump again.
It was about when
you all are giving
user reports of like
patient profiles, let's say.
So what was previously long
900-page listings in PDF form,
now you're doing interactive,
probably more elegant web
facing applications
for viewing these.
For us on the CRO side,
which Bo helpfully just
describe to us something you
all don't have to deal with,
we have to receive feedback
from the monitor and safety
committees.
It'd be convenient if
the Shiny app allowed
them to do so directly
in a way that links it
to the data they
were actually viewing
at the time they gave feedback.
Because we lose a lot of context
sometimes when they try to tell
us, oh, we looked at this
patient profile and patient 001
has an abnormal lab value and
we're like going back through
the data going, wait, what?
You know in the Shiny app
seems like an opportune way
to make that easier.
It is indeed.
But I remember one project where
it was for specific people team
and then we had surprising
reaction from the end user
because they were actually
not really convinced
about the Shiny app.
They would actually prefer using
the PDF, the table listing,
these frightening things.
Just because there were like
many options in the safety
explorer widgets,
stuff like that.
Too many options, we
didn't know where to click.
Yeah, that wasn't clear.
In some situation,
they would end up
with data we don't really
know what it means.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Oh, sorry.
It depends if you're already
familiar with these kind
of tools.
If you are familiar with
web application or not,
I would say.
That's such a good point.
We've gotten that
feedback before too.
We build something
really elegant
and then someone says, ah,
but can't you just give me
900 pages in paper.
I feel your pain.
It was making me think of a
meetup we had before with Ryan
at Veterans Affairs on going
from this hundred-- multiple--
I don't know how many hundreds
of pages PDF into a Shiny app
to really change
the conversation
with their executives being
able to bring that Shiny
app to meetings.
I just put the link in the chat
if it's helpful for anybody.
But Marlene, I love a
question you asked in the chat
a bit earlier.
And we'd love to have you.
You jump in here.
Oh sure.
David, Bo, hi.
Thanks for joining us.
And I'm Marlene Hanken.
I'm over here on the west coast
of the US, Southern California.
I usually ask the aspirational
questions in the Hangout
so I'm going to do
that again here,
especially with all the
great conversations happening
in the Shiny Conference
incredibly inspirational
for people who feel
like middle of the road
getting the hang of Shiny.
But I wanted to ask, do you have
any personal aspirations when
it comes to using R versus--
I'm sure you have
corporate goals, right?
But what do you want to
do on, a personal level,
with your R and Shiny journey.
I want everyone to use
Git so they won't send code
to me in the attachment.
I don't blame you.
It's not specific
to R or any language,
but I think it would
make my life much easier.
How about you, David?
Yeah, if I think about the--
has to do Shiny
Server Pro migration,
I would say, yeah, that would
be good if everyone could
use version control on Git.
Because sometimes I had
to look for some code
application, which
was not even on Git
so we extend the
code by mail and I
had to deploy the application
on the Posit Connect which
was, if you imagine, there
are like 6,000 applications.
It's a bit challenging.
And then it's not only
Git, but also package
dependencies with renv.
When you start your
project on any project
not only in Shiny app,
but could a mantle,
could be even a
book, for instance.
When I wrote the book, like the
outstanding Shiny [INAUDIBLE]
book, I first thought
about renv freezing
the packages I was using.
Because I knew, at
some point, I would
install a version which
would break everything
and it happens.
And I was able to
recover because of that.
And that can really
make your life easier.
That's also makes your
life easier in CI/CD
when you use renv.
You can use renv block to
restore packages seamlessly.
And then it works better
we Posit Connect as well.
So it's all benefits.
Great.
Thank you both for sharing.
Thank you for all these
great questions too.
Something I wanted to ask.
Sometimes, we ask this
towards the very end,
but I want to put it in
here because, Marlene, you
reminded me, I love
getting some of these more
like human-centric
questions too.
But, David, I'm curious
what is the best career
advice you've ever received
or advice that you've given?
And it doesn't have to be best.
Maybe just the first
that comes to mind.
I was to remind myself not
to use the word best there.
That's tough one.
That's a tough one.
That's not a technical
advice I gave.
That's just a mindset
advice probably
like never give up, right?
It's hard today, it
will be better tomorrow.
These kind of things.
Like inside in the
keynote, I was like--
I always go back to the
keynote, but there are
days you want to quit, right?
It's hard to make things work
well using best practices.
But in the long run, you learn
about a lot about yourself.
You collaborate
better with people.
I mean, for everything
in life, it's
hard if you going to have
raise your kids it's hard.
Do stuff, it's hard.
But also you could
learn point from.
So believe in yourself
and never give up.
Thank you.
Omar, I see you have
your hand raised here.
Do you want to jump
in with your question?
Yeah, I wasn't sure what
the proper [INAUDIBLE]----
No.
No, that's great.
And thank you I can
put the reminder here
because I know we're coming
in at different times.
Feel free to raise
your hand on Zoom
if you want to ask questions.
You can also use the
Slido link in the chat
too ask anonymously.
And then can also put
them in Zoom chat too.
So thanks.
Thanks, Omar.
Sure.
Thank you.
So David you were
talking a little bit
about the [INAUDIBLE] and using
Connect for CI/CD deployment.
So the one thing with
Connect is it's a pull.
So it pulls from--
it's designed to pull things in.
Sometimes that's different
from a enterprise scenario
where they're
expecting everything
to be packaged up and sent
to the server instead.
Did you use [INAUDIBLE]
to perhaps address
some of those
challenges around that?
Just curious.
Yeah.
So, for instance, when
we have like Shiny
app for instance we want to
send to Posit Connect, so
first of all, we make
sure it's using renv, right?
We have frozen dependencies.
Then we have the CI/CD pipeline.
We have a specific
section in the YAML file
which is restoring
packages in the runner.
And then you have some
instructions to deploy the app
on Posit Connect.
So you need to use
the Connect API.
So you need an API key on
different things in between
to enter too much into details.
So Posit Connect
doesn't use renv when
it restarts the application,
it uses Packrat.
But if you have frozen
dependencies in the runner,
it's much, much easier
than if they are packages,
you don't even know
where they're coming from
and you try to really
push everything.
And then you have error
messages everywhere
in the Posit Connect.
So from time to time you
see the programs, right,
but they are
significantly reduced.
Great.
Thank you so much for that.
Thank you.
See a few hands raised.
Eric, I know you had a question
earlier in the chat too.
You want to jump in?
Yeah, I just saw with
that flow your activity,
I was afraid I was
going to get lost.
First, David hadn't
asked me to do this,
but he didn't mention that he
has written this amazing book.
This, if you are doing anything
intermediate or complex
on Shiny, you need this book.
Especially for
someone like me who
does not have any
design background
whatsoever or web
development training
before getting into Shiny.
It has been a huge
valuable resource for me.
So thank you, David, for
providing that of course.
To my actual question,
certainly, you've
seen in talks even at the
conference or in other venues,
that we're seeing
Shiny used at more
places in the pharmaceutical
area of development
as to what Bo was saying
with DMC interactions.
So I guess, in
your opinion, what
do you think are the biggest
hurdles for those that maybe
are coming new to pharma,
but also new to Shiny
for learning of
the best techniques
to develop an application
that's effective,
especially with the nuances and
situations that we encounter
in pharma quite a bit.
Just curious on
your take on that.
It's more like the
flow outside Shiny.
It's not just Shiny, but it's
the way you would learn Shiny.
When I learned at the beginning
I really learned reactivity.
I learned that using reactive,
using observe, observe event,
isolate.
But didn't learn about renv.
I learned later.
When I did the mistakes
putting everything
to Shiny app [INAUDIBLE]
to Posit Connect having
my deployment fading because I
didn't have the right version
or whatever.
This just kind of flow.
So when you're using
Shiny, it's really--
If you ever did,
like PHP, with MySQL,
you could build everything
together, it's not that easy.
And when I discovered Shiny in
2012 at the end of the year,
it was super easy to develop
this interactive application.
You have this select input,
you change the table,
the address works
in five minutes.
But that's a trap.
Because in the
long run, you would
have more and more features.
And then in the end,
you have spaghetti code
which is harder and
harder to maintain.
So yeah.
There is no strong
emphasis around modules.
So if you look at Emily's
talk from yesterday,
modules should be one of
the first concept you should
have when you adopt Shiny.
I see Eric
clapping to that too.
I've been a fan of
modules as he knows.
Yes.
So I know there's a
lot of so many questions
that we could probably make this
Hangout longer in the future,
but I want to make sure I get to
some of the anonymous questions
too.
And I don't know
if, Bo or David,
you want to answer this one.
And then, Mike,
I see your hands.
I will definitely
call on you next.
But the question was,
how are the data teams
structured among
engineering and analytics?
Are they siloed or integrated in
terms of the end-to-end project
workflow?
Bo, do you want to
answer that one?
Or David?
Who wants to take that one?
Can you repeat the question?
So the question is,
how are the data teams
structured among engineering
and analytics at Novartis?
Are they siloed or integrated in
terms of the end-to-end project
workflow?
I guess, in the
pharma, someone
who's also in the
pharma industry,
please correct me if I'm wrong.
My understanding of a
data engineer's role
does not really exist
normally in a pharma setting.
We have armies of trial
statisticians who I guess falls
more under the analytics side--
our bigger team, actually,
our "umbrella team" is called--
yeah.
Someone typed
"statistical programmer."
That's my assumption,
but I didn't
want to make that call in
case-- because I've never
worked in an organization
with a team that's
titled Data Engineers.
But if we're talking about
people who create the data,
curate the data based
on specifications,
validate the data
and pipe them down,
stream for data scientists
and statisticians
to create the analysis
on, yes, that team
is mostly traditionally called
Stats Programmer in pharma
and they are two
different organizations.
There are different ways
of organizing the two teams
in different pharma companies.
Sometimes, they're in
completely different branches
of the company with different
set of higher management.
So basically, sometimes, the the
level of communication between
stats programming
and statistics,
which mirrors to data
engineers and data scientist--
or data analysts, in
the general term--
sometimes it happens
way up in the structure.
Sometimes in the middle.
There merged together into
a bigger organization.
But on a day-to-day
basis, in every project,
in every clinical
project, you would
have an assigned
programmer who's
the engineer, who
creates the data,
and the statistician
assigned to each study.
Even though are management.
In management structure,
they're in different teams
with reporting to
different managers.
But the two functions
always work together
on a clinical project.
Thanks, Bo.
I see there's a lot of thoughts
shared here in the chat too.
I wondered if, Sep,
you wanted to jump in
with your perspective?
No, it was a minor add.
There's all sorts
of pharma companies
at all kinds of levels that
all do different things.
I'm sure from Novartis
to smaller companies
is different so.
Yeah.
And Eric, I know
you mentioned what?
You call it at Eli Lilly, too.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah.
It's basically even
though I don't quite
agree with the term, they call
that the data sciences group,
but not the typical data
science that you and I or many
in this call would expect.
But they're the ones
handling the day-to-day
of getting the data
delivered correctly
or queries are answered.
And they have their personnel
embedded into the trial
team or the study team
so that each trial gets
one of their representatives
on, of course, stats,
and programming, and
medical, and all that.
So they're pretty seamless
in the trial process.
I definitely don't interact with
them as much from a capability
perspective.
But certainly, from a
day-to-day trial perspective,
they're a huge part of it.
Well, thank you.
Mike, I see you have your
hand raised, want to jump in?
Hi, yeah.
I mean, this is going to be
a softball question for David
and Bo, but I'm super
impressed by what's
happening at Novartis where
you've built-- essentially,
the data science team have built
these LEGO bricks for modules
for building Shiny apps.
Then other people who
want to build Shiny apps
aren't starting
from a blank sheet,
but they're reusing
those LEGO pieces.
Do you want to talk
us through that?
Because I think that's
a novel approach.
[DOORBELL]
Someone's getting
their doorbell rung.
It's Mike.
So Mike, when you say about
the LEGO pieces are you talking
about data pipeline
presentation from-- yeah,
we had some presentation at RN
Pharma some years ago, where,
yeah, there are some modules
to develop visualization
for clinical trials.
And then you can combine
those modules together
to create your
application so you don't
need to develop them yourself.
And that's basically--
Yeah, I don't know how
many modules we have,
but we probably had 30, 32
module, which you can basically
plug into your app and then
depending what you want to do,
if you want to do safety
explorer, patient profile,
whatever.
But there is still this issue
where you have application
with very specific
needs, and in that case,
people need to dive in the
code and at some point, that's
inevitable.
But yeah, for sure that's
a big change for us.
The main challenge is also like
making rules modules, following
best practices in terms of
software development using renv,
everything with package, CI/CD.
We are a team, you know?
We are not even 10 in our team.
So that's a lot on our shoulders
Yeah, I couldn't say it before.
From time to time, you hear
people are not super satisfied
because this thing is not
doing what it's intended.
But, in the meantime,
you also have
people that are really
thankful to what you are doing.
So that's also rewarding
as a developer.
You can jump on this, Bo.
We have a bunch
of questions so
if it's OK if I kind of rapid
fire go through a few of them
here.
Another one on
Slido was my group
is using bs4Dash and
Shiny pretty extensively
and I really love it.
The biggest frustration
that this person runs into
is if they want to
put in custom CSS.
And, David, they were wondering
if you have any advice.
It depends what
they want to achieve,
but if they want to
have questions in CSS
and bs4Dash, they won't be
able to use [? bsLeap, ?]
because bs4Dash actually
uses like a refactor
version of Bootstrap,
specifically Bootstrap 4.
So if you ever
use Bootstrap kit,
you will have the same
variables, the same size
variables.
So it won't work.
So if you want to develop
something for the long run,
I would say may want
to go changing Sass--
the Sass code.
So when I say Sass, it's
not SAS as a statistician,
it's Sass, Syntactically
Awesome Style Sheets.
But that's another language.
So yeah.
There is a bit of
learning curve.
But in the long run, you better
organize your style in the app
and that's the best
practice to grow.
If it's just like
10 lines of CSS,
you may not want to use Sass.
So it depends how many
they want to customize.
I look, there's
another question.
I think it was from Damian.
If you're still on on
interacting with users,
do you want to ask that?
Yeah, sure.
Hi, everyone.
My name is Damian.
I'm the president of Appsilon.
I'm really happy to be
here and really enjoying
the conference so far.
Right now, I'm in Bulgaria.
But I'm actually on
workcation, so I just came back
from India and Vietnam.
So really enjoying
the remote setup.
I wanted to ask you
about the users.
Because the beauty of Shiny
is that we can build apps
like very fast in
small iterations
and we can keep getting the
feedback and upgrading on them.
And this makes it like a
bleeding edge kind of software
that we can provide
to the users.
And I know that you also
shared that it is not
that easy to get feedback
from the users directly.
So I hope to hear a
little bit more about it.
How do you cope with this?
So just to know whether your
application are properly used,
whether these kind
of things right
on how people are using
the applications typically.
So this is, I'll
be honest, this is
something we will start
to do at Novartis.
So I did it like
in the open source,
but I am really talking what
we are doing at Novartis.
So what we have?
We have the tracker in Posit
Connect, which basically-- it's
an application I developed
last year when I was in Japan.
So when you travel,
you can do many things.
And this queries the API
to get all applications.
For all application,
you get who is accessing
the application, how much
time, which basically give you
some insights.
Like if you develop an
application for several teams,
you can have some insight
of which team is using
the most this
application and how
you could target your supports.
Like if you see one team
is using the application
20 times more than
another one, maybe you
want to invest more people
to provide two paths here.
And so this is like
a global solution
that you can apply to all
applications that are deployed.
And that's not something you
need to add to the application.
And that that's
important that that's
something that works
automatically as soon
as the app is on the server.
And, on the other side, if you
want to know how people are
using the app,
like in-app usage,
you may know like ShinyHeatmap--
that's a study
from an experiment
I made around heatmap.js,
a JavaScript library.
Because in the past I
was using [INAUDIBLE]
to track usage on my website.
And one day, I was just
wondering why shouldn't I
just use ShinyHeatmap?
Oh, sorry, I would use
[INAUDIBLE] on my Shiny apps.
So I tried the tracking code
to put it in the Shiny app
and then I couldn't
see anything.
It didn't work.
And I collected this report
and they told me, yes, it
won't work with
Shiny because that's
quite specific technology.
And then I took the heatmap.js
and brought some very simple
code with R and JavaScript,
put it in a package
and released the ShinyHeatmap.
So basically, each time
you click in your app,
it will record the
x and y location,
and then aggregate the
data at the end of the day.
So you can see where
people are clicking.
For instance, you can
identify some dead zones
in the application which
will help you to refactor
the design at some point.
If you realize there is
an app that nobody visits,
maybe that's because
it's badly designed
or because, for
whatever reason, yeah.
So that's essentially what
we would like to bring.
And there is also user feedback
like sending communications
to users.
So this one is a bit
more active and you
can be frustrated,
because sometimes you
don't get the answer.
People are very busy.
And then-- Yeah, that's it.
Thank you.
I know we are quickly coming
to the end of our hour here
unfortunately.
So our Posit team is
talking behind the scenes
that there's so many
awesome questions here
that we will think about how we
can gather any questions that
didn't get answered
and maybe think
about a blog post or
some other resource.
So I just wanted
to let everybody
know that in case your
questions didn't get answered,
there's so many great ones.
Niels, I see you had asked
something in the chat.
I think around using APIs
in addition to Shiny.
Do you want to jump
in and ask that?
NIELS: Yes, sure.
So I was wondering, especially
for bigger applications,
if you want to separate server
from cloud side rendering,
maybe add using
React as a front-end
and then separate it from the
back end using [? firmer ?]
APIs might be easier.
Is that something you would do
as well or only pure you Shiny?
From app supporting
clinical projects
is an easier answer is
that we don't use anything
beside Shiny right now.
Because first, we
don't really have
super big app, super complicated
app, and super big sample size.
Clinical trial data
are quite small
compared to many
other industries.
And second, is we
actually tried React
before separating the
front end and back
end just to improve flexibility
and the visual effect
to make it look better.
But eventually, like
I said in the comment,
our team is very small.
Like David mentioned, our
goal is not to write a tool,
maintain a tool for each
study that come to us,
but to create something
that we can ship off
to our statisticians
to use on their own
and to manage on their own.
And we have much, much
better adoption of R
especially with the younger
generation of statisticians
coming in from academia.
Many of them are
quite fluent in R,
but I think we haven't
made the pivot.
Well, I don't think
it's necessary for trial
statisticians.
R is still the one
of the best languages
that they are the most familiar
with coming in from academia.
For some other bigger
scale apps like the one
that David worked on for the
HR data, or the POS, maybe.
You're right, Bo.
I totally agree.
We decided to go for
R. At least tomorrow,
we say, people, yeah, we have to
go to [? Julia ?] or whatever.
At some point,
there'll be a big plus.
R is doing what we want to do.
It's doing it well.
Now we have many tools.
If we want to speed
up Shiny apps,
we use parallel packages to
some speed up computations.
If we start to develop
something with React,
the problem is we are like
three in the team to React.
So if we leave in
the future, then
who is going to
maintain the tool?
So if we develop it in R,
maybe it's not as fast.
Maybe it's not as optimized.
But at least we can find someone
to maintain it in the future.
And this is what
matters when you are
in the industry at some point.
OK.
Maybe a quick like 10 second
answer from you, David and Bo.
For teams who are just starting
to learn how to use Shiny
or maybe helping
somebody else learn,
what are one of your
favorite resources?
David, you want to go first?
Right.
Sorry, I had to cut.
I couldn't hear the end.
Bo, do you want to go first?
What is one of your
favorite resources
for learning Shiny or
something you'd recommend?
For me, personally,
Stack Overflow.
But for someone who's
just starting off,
I think a lot of the gallery
and the tutorials on Posit's
website are--
as I understand,
there are current,
there are news articles.
that you can always go
back-- go back to the--
I think there's a series of
what 15, 20 videos of Shiny
tutorials from the
very beginning.
I found that to
be really helpful.
Yeah, later at least mastering
Shiny I believe it's in,
its in version two right now.
Only a couple of years ago
Thank you all for sharing the
links in the chat too as we go.
That's so helpful.
And I know, Maya, you just
mentioned R4DS community
to help answer
questions too and that's
an amazing suggestion as well.
If we want to share
the link for how
people can join that community
too that would be really cool.
Awesome.
Well, I know we are coming
to the end of the time here.
And I don't want anybody to
be late for the next event.
And I did just want
to remind people
that you'll go back to
the Shiny Conference page
and use Hopin to get
to the next event.
But if you had fun today
and want to join us again,
we do have these Data Science
Hangouts every Thursday
from 12:00 to 1:00 Eastern time.
So the same time
and the same place.
And so I'm just going to
put this link into the chat.
If you wanted to add it to your
calendar you can do so there.
There's also a Data Science
Hangout site on the Posit site
that you can check out
recordings of past sessions
as well.
With everybody here, I just have
to also put a little plug here
that the call for speakers
is open for the Posit
Conference in September
in Chicago as well.
So I just wanted to share that
blog post announcing that too.
Thank you so much, David and
Bo, for joining us and answering
everyone's questions.
Thank you all for jumping
over here to the Hangout.
It's been fun
spending time with you
and seeing all the great
discussions in the chat.
I'm not able to follow
along with everything
as we go so I'm looking forward
to reading it after as well.
Thank you everybody.